hello ladles and jelly spoons I'm Dave
Rubin this is the reuin report and
you're watching on YouTube so we got to
get to it quick I've got Aron Foley I've
got Fred carer and I've got Kelly Carlin
and we are starting off with clearly the
most important story of the year the
Oscars let's get to it General feelings
to start eron what do you think the best
show I think I've ever seen oh wow I
have it on tape I've watched it four
times today uh no I thought it was
thought it was a stink bomb uh I could
thing I was drunk um now there was a
there was a couple ones I thought Seth
maybe I thought one every 25 jokes
worked and then at the very end he's
like thanks for staying it's been the
longest show ever then I'm going to do
another number because uh the show was
about him all right so chalk Aaron Foley
up as unimpressed Fred carer what did
you think I have to agree and I love the
Oscars I used to go to the Oscars and
seen many pictures of you holding Oscars
with with stars you're you're always
holding them very tight and the Oscar in
another hand I used to crash the Oscar
ended up on stage a couple years but it
was a different era they had better
shows last nights I think they were
trying too hard they're making a big
effort for this younger demographic
which I guess they got according to the
uh neelon today but I think they really
missed the boat and Seth should uh
should continue writing and I think
let's get Billy Crystal or Eddie Murphy
or a couple a comedian who can respond
to the what's happening at the show that
was missing yeah because when you want
young people Billy crystal is what comes
to mind Kelly Carlin what did you think
or Shirley Bassie and Barbara
sty uh I'm so confused about what the
cast of Chicago has to do with anything
I'm I'm just dumbfounded every time
they'd show up I'm like what they're
here again what's going on I was
confused the whole time I just kept
writing on Twitter confused I'm confused
again what's going on it seemed it
seemed like a big M mishmash of stuff
just a lot of stuff Christ Stewart was
definitely confused uh
I didn't watch the red carpet and I
don't know uh I'm not on my Kristen
Stewart uh Twitter feed every two
seconds so I had no idea she cut her
foot the first time you see her she's
she's hobbling out she's like a bruised
arm her hair is all like I was like what
did she just bang a cameraman right
before she went on stage like what is
happening she looked like a hot mess
yeah is it harder for a woman you think
because we're so focused you know on the
looks for the the guys can come out in
all these ridiculous beards and their
hair is all mess the women have look so
perfect yeah they're either the SNK
you're either too skinny or you're too
fat in this town and there's a lot of
skinny girls out there and so a lot of
things was you know feed this girl feed
this girl I I can't even imagine it's
it's impossible standards you're screwed
either way I just I just wanted her to
like walk properly and not look
completely blazing High you know I mean
it's like got a high bar for her have we
confirmed that she wasn't High because I
didn't realize the ankle thing either
and she looked like she had just done
drugs stumbled out and and then just
fumbled through the thing she could have
been on painkillers I mean I don't know
I I my favorite moment was when Jennifer
Lawrence tripped I just thought just
like yes real moment thank you and she
handled herself so well she was like
joking around and yeah she was awesome
she's cool what do you guys think of the
idea that the host can sort of never win
because pretty much exactly what you all
said that you know no matter how good he
is you're going to get the snark on
Twitter of course and people are going
to go crazy now you're the non-c
comedian at the table
so as a regular citizen which is how we
refer to non
comedians yes as a regular citizen of
the United States what what do you think
for the host is it is it an unwinable
proposition basically but I think they
had the Biggest Loser last night in Seth
and and I don't mean to criticize him
just for that but but it was it was
poorly done on his part and the writing
was terrible where was Bruce fanch where
were those jokes when when there was a
trip on stage you're supposed to come
and respond to that trip there was not
one mention of anything that happened in
the show was all scripted I think Seth
McFarland could have just taped that
thing a week ago and and phoned it in
and that was missing yeah I think they
need to get the Pixar writers because
the Pixar writers have a way of writing
jokes for like the the grown-ups in a
theater and at the same time the kids
and it's the same thing with the Oscars
you have to please The Insider Hollywood
crowd and you have to please 10 billion
people watching around the world so
there's I know it can be done and it has
some years but and I and Seth McFarland
very funny extremely talented human
being it just wasn't funny I wasn't
laughing sock puet sock puppets were
great moment people love the so he's so
he is guaranteed like super talented
super funny I just thought some of it it
is it's about pleasing the masses and he
just it was so specific of just like
snark Ville and pushing the envelope and
that doesn't really work for Oscars you
have to please like my parents and you
got to be a little classy too yeah well
speaking of classy and this constant
need to please think there's something
weird about how when they do something a
little edgy if you can call a Lincoln
joke about being assassinated 150 years
ago edgy but it's somehow that the these
Elite Liberals are seem to be the most
offended people even though they're
supposed to have the best sense of humor
what's the deal with that you Republican
I was curious along the Lincoln
assassination lines everybody was
sitting in the boxes seemed to win did
you notice that so I don't know I think
next year you're going to have people
you know insisting celebrities nominated
are going to be insisting they in one of
those boxes or they're not coming to the
show I never saw anyone sit in a balcony
before this year was that was that a nod
to Lincoln what was that it might have
been it might have been all right well
let's move on because the uh the big
Fallout after the Oscars you don't think
the Oscars are going to happen and then
someone's not going to get in trouble on
uh on the Twitter do you uh the onion
tweeted about uh I got to get her name
right quaven Wallace she was in Beasts
of the Southern Wild and she's the
9-year-old Act actress and uh well let's
put up the uh the tweet at the onion
everyone else seems afraid to say it but
that
quaven Wallace is kind of a CW word
right okay there it is thank God for my
phonetics um we Kelly I'm going to start
with you on this one because
God uh language comedy these are things
you're very interested in your father
George Carlin is the god father of both
of those things of the word and of of
the SE of all of those seven or 50
filthy words the list keeps getting
bigger actually which he would be very
upset by where should we start with this
take it away well first of all when I
saw this today I thought this is this is
the living room joke this isn't the
Twitter joke this is the joke that
someone comes up with it in the living
room who's very high who's been doing
bong hits all night long and probably a
few shots and they turn around and it's
one of my more irreverent comedian
friends and they say it and we all laugh
because we all know it's not true it's
not what it's about it's about Hollywood
it's about you know people are
impossible and clearly this girl is not
impossible but this is not something you
tweet yeah and and you know and I and I
just it would have been okay if Gilbert
godfried had tweeted it because then he
would have apologized right away and
everything would have been okay yeah he
might have apologized before might have
and then after again uh now this and
then today people are like bringing my
dad dad's name up with this and then of
course they ask me what would he think
and I don't know he's dead um
but um I you know it's I don't know I
these days I just don't know anymore
about jokes it's all it's either to PC
or we're
too
I exactly you ran out of words because
you didn't want to offend anybody Fred
Fred what what do you think about this
you it's um it's a a reference to child
stars and many of us have worked with
them um but very obviously very
inappropriate I think there should be a
moratorium on using the c-word on anyone
who was born this Millennium and she was
born in 2003 I think if you go the 90s
and before '90s prior to that cord okay
so this is an age issue basically which
you seem to be for a lot of people sure
because it's a NY if everything being
equal if this had been said about an
couter I'm pretty sure that that an
apology would have not have been issued
likewe all right retweet
retweet you can only retweet once I'm
pretty I would I would have kept
retweeting you would have started other
Twitter accounts would have been like
fake Aaron Foley retweet fake Aaron
Foley too retweet all right well Aaron
Foley no I wouldn't I wouldn't even call
her the I would never I mean that's what
it is it's like you know you got to have
maybe like a some Twitter filter like a
draft or like yeah you high five your
buddy and then you go du but I'm you
know not a complete idiot you know it's
it's so outrageous that which which is
alarming too because the onion I mean
who doesn't love the onion theyve like
the smartest like they don't need to do
any of that like they're so above that
and they're interesting but I was
tweeting like crazy last night and it's
a snark Fest and it's what you do during
these Live Events and you know and I
always feel dirty afterwards because I
know I've said a few things that I
wouldn't normally say and but I felt
like like I'd been on a cocaine binge
afterwards so I'm thinking possibly this
person just kind of didn't really
realize how out of bounds it was and it
went out there and this person has been
fired from The Onion now which is weird
well speaking of being fired so of
course the onion did Issue an apology
because this is America in 2013 and
everyone has to apologize for something
so let's uh let's take a look at the
apology itself dear readers on behalf of
the onion I offer my personal apology uh
to
qu Quint Tarantino Quinton Tarantino
Wallace and the academy em Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences for the tweet
that was circulated last night during
the Oscars it was crude and offensive
not to mention inconsistent with the
onions commitment to parody and satire
however biting no person should ever be
subjected s to such a shame a senseless
humorless comment masquerading as satire
the Tweet was taken down within an hour
of publication we have instituted new
and Tighter Twitter procedures to ensure
that this kind of mistake does not occur
again etc etc and this is from the onion
CEO Steve Hannah the interesting word
here that I think we should focus on is
the word mistake because if had the
reaction been different well no one
would have thought this was a mistake
and that's the fine line that comedians
have to play on how how do you deal with
that when you're when you're writing
jokes and you're on stage how do you
deal with that um well I don't use the c
c word uh I kind of reel that in yeah so
many times where I'm like that would be
the best punchline and then I'm like no
I got to rewrite that so I can still
have a career uh but yeah I mean honest
to God I think it it went too far they
apologized in my book I'm like the guy I
don't the guy or woman it's a guy
doesn't need to be fired it it's so
ridic like all right it was a bad call
you take it down you apologize you move
on like the fact that it's still going
on oh the you know just wrap it up you
isn't that funny though we're all
assuming that it's a man right and what
if it was a woman because it could have
been because you know women have
opinions about other women and
especially women who are you know
considered and the seword um you
know but one thing I know that my dad
did say about this is that the
comedian's job is to find the edge and
cross it that is their job and they did
find an edge and they and they crossed
it last night okay great now we know
where that edge is but then again going
after a 9-year-old child that's an
that's an edge that I'm not quite sure
you even want to kind of like maybe th
like
buty I don't know like
a pain like you know you could have
tried the joke in another way as well I
think you have to apologize for that
letter he said tighter Twitter in there
controls and Tighter didn't he say that
sounds like something you might have to
apologize I think he's going to have to
apologize for that beautiful letter of
apology apologizing for apology that's
that's actually what's coming up next
all right let's get off the Oscars for
just a second if we can move on to
something slightly more serious
America's crumbling uh the sequester
have you guys heard about this thing
basically some budget cuts are going to
K are going to kick in I'm I'm not going
to give you every little breakdown about
it because go somewhere else and find
the serious stuff but basically some
budget cuts are kicking in about 85 uh
billion dollar and the Republicans are
saying uh it's going to gut the military
Democrats are saying we got to raise
taxes to take care of it it's the same
old same old fight that we're always in
my question to you guys is is this just
simply how politics now works that we
just get to crisis mode and then some
sort of half-ass re resolution Fred what
do you think I came up with the adage
about uh 10 years ago that all politics
is selfish and it's based on what tip
O'Neal said when he was speaker of the
house which was all politics is local
and that's what it is now you have 535
members of the House and Senate who all
they care about is the next election
period and they're not getting long
they're not doing the kinds of things
they need to do to solve the country's
crisis I'm all for this sequester the
budget cuts let's give it a try I think
government will adjust they're doing all
the scare tactics now that we've always
heard in government doing they did that
in California when with Proposition 13 I
just think that we should try it and see
what happens yeah Aaron what do you
think can we deal with a world without
government if they shut down what would
what would happen gosh well I'd probably
be you know just go right through
downtown abbey one one at season one and
two uh so many I have a lot of free time
on my hands if they well I wrote down a
couple things I was thinking about this
basic premise of like why don't you this
why don't you like everyone's like oh
reach out to the people here's an idea
like do you do party line versus
constituents or I don't know what that
word is Con
constituents the voters yes quani quis
qu tantino you know what I mean it's
like the people don't want this gu wow
here here's the thought why don't you go
around and and ask the people who you
represent but no one no one cares about
that it's just like yeah Party Line
Party Line party line and the whole I
love I these words are so funny the
sequestration sequestration yes all I
could think of was sequester and
castration that's all I could think of
but then I thought if you sequestered
all these people at the threat of
castration we would get things moving in
about 2 hours they would just be like
boom budget absolutely done Kelly what
do you think uh you know money money
money money money it's all about money
there's too much money in politics and
like you said these people need to get
reelected and the campaign cycle never
quits never stops so they're always
raising money this is about pleasing the
people who really pay for these
elections and the citizens don't get any
Say in any of this and and and what I
really feel this is all about ultimately
is that the right and the left I mean
we're heading towards some sort of crazy
Civil War I mean I feel like this is the
mid East I feel like we now live in the
mid East and this is the palestini and
the Israelis and there's no coming
together there's no talking there's
there's no compromise and I'm like well
let's just you know let's get down to it
folks you know in a bizarre way I think
the analogy works because it's become
like if you give one inch if you give
one inch of land all you've shown is
weakness and that's so the antithesis
really of what politics is so I think
this is going to be the question that
every week on this show that I'm going
to deal with here is we all talk about
this we all talk about the money and the
gridlock and and the fine people that
The Young Turks talk about it all the
time but what can we do besides all
saying it now you ran for president of
the United States for the Republicans I
wasn't allowed to announce that until
you were sitting here uh otherwise you
were going to get don't turn this thing
off get past security uh what do we do
about this really besides you're saying
us the money all the time what do we do
what do people do we got to start
getting along and I fa Obama for that
and I said that in in my campaign and I
liked Obama although I was a maxed out
Hillary Clinton donor so I kind of came
around reluctantly but he needs to to be
more of a politician with the Congress
he needs to go reach out to them Reagan
did that right when he was
elected didn't he try that his first ter
not he didn't invite mitcho conell to
the White House for 18 months for just a
one-on-one thing and then somebody said
to me well do you know Mitch McConnell
would you ever want to S with Mitch
McConnell really I mean they that's what
you got to do that's what that glad
handing is you take a guy like dual
Patrick who's the governor of
Massachusetts he is great and he's a
politician who likes people and goes
we've got an intellectual for president
he's a great speaker but he's not a
people person he's not comfortable gring
with all these Biden in I mean I feel
like all we hear are stories of we're
trying we're trying we're trying Obama
trying in the first four years and now
it seems like he won the you know and
everyone's like you only have now one
year in your second term to jam down the
entire agenda so now it just it just I
think there's a very simple solution
that is just to split up the United
States very easy to do Democrats take
the coast Republicans take the middle
and we're done why we are done what is
it about Democrats that they like to
live near water water in big cities
we're very thirst very thirst very
thirsty people very thirsty because
we're help we're trying to help
everybody yeah I always think it's maybe
because Democrats want an easy ES Escape
in case the Republicans really do take
over getting their
yacht get their yacht my yach is PED
outside oh yes those Democrats with
their Yachts all right all right let's
keep talking politics for a little bit
uh and as much as I think the gridlock
is going to be one of the things we talk
about here uh this also uh the media
which has consistently failed us all the
way around every day uh
MSNBC uh has hired Robert Gibbs who was
uh president President Obama's press
secretary and David Axelrod who is his
chief campaign uh officer uh and they
are now working as analysts on
MSNBC now before you jump down my throat
uh yes Fox News has hired Sarah Palin in
the past and new Gingrich so yes maybe
they're just being as bad as them but
should progressives be a little bit
better that's where I'm going to start
this thing Aaron what do you think load
the
deck load it up I mean honest to God
there's no like it's so split everything
is so split and now the media is
completely I watch MSNBC like a couple
it would be refreshing now and then if
someone's like what I remember uh like
on Rachel M A couple weeks ago she's
like what's going on with the drones and
that secret report and I thought wow we
haven't heard one like call Obama out
like I think maybe in the last you know
couple of years so I I mean but but the
also the flip side is like if I want to
get you know throw Obama under the bus
you hit Fox if I want to get this is you
know pro Democrat let's everything's
going well hit MSNBC and then one time I
was like I'm going to watch the Nightly
News I want to see what my parents are
are getting and it was like you know 20
minutes on a chicken farm in Illinois so
I was like forget it I'm going to go
back to MSNBC you know what I mean it
really is like you got to pick your it's
like cheerleading you know which which
yeah it's ridiculous Kelly where does it
leave CNN if there if MSNBC is going to
go down the route that fox has gone down
just the other side where does that
leave that Network that people used to
trust that now nobody watches where are
they uh I don't know I can't stand Wolf
Blitzer the minute he comes on I used to
love CNN I mean back in the day they
were the ones they were hiding under the
bed in the you know in the Iraq War uh a
CNN wants to be this middle ground but
it's just it's mushy it's it's it's like
a big mushy Pete Moss bog there's
nothing there um the fourth estate it's
gone it's disappeared there's there's no
one deciding how to filter this
information there's I mean you know
where's Edward R Murrow uh ever you know
I blame I mean we've got Reagan who
undid a lot of it you know with the uh
the
fairness fairness Doctrine went away
then Clinton and the communications act
let all these corporations buy all this
media up the conglomerates It's All
About Eyes and it's all about ratings
it's not about information anymore so
you know what at least the Buy bias is
front and center now before you have to
educate people and say oh the the net
the Nightly News is biased the New York
Times actually is biased now it's like
of course it's biased except people
don't think it's biased people who
liberals watch MSNBC think that's the
truth and the conservatives watch Fox
and things that's the truth and they're
both screwed yeah and I actually think
it's dangerous that we constantly are
reinforcing the very things that we
believe and never challenging any of
those and then we get gridlock in
Washington no it's it's wonder why yeah
sometimes I I go like three shows in
like Ed Show Rachel mat and then like
three shows in and I'm just like yeah
come on what yeah come and then I'm just
like all right I get so riled up and
then I think well there's also an other
opinions out there there's other and and
the thing is like yeah I'm like a you
know pretty intense Democrat but I know
my par has got major issues like I also
would like to sit down with like a
normal Republican I mean there's only
three or four left only because he
hasn't spoken four
minutes no I need to learn I want to be
informed I know there's like and that's
why it's so sad because there should be
a coming together of great ideas on the
Republican side and the Democratic side
that's what how it should work and
that's that's we need a three-party
system I that's the only thing I think
we absolutely system yeah or a 10 party
system can work and they used to work
and acts good for him he's a political
consultant made good let him go make
some money now and tout his his
Administration and I think it's great
but but we have lost the objectivity in
in media and that's sad and fox started
it and MSNBC is around to give that
balance and CNN was there but now CNN is
going to go entertainment and so you're
going to have to go to newspapers or
stations or networks like RT Russian
television BBC that are actually being
very objective and I think those are
going to English is amazing yeah they're
going to start being the alternative for
people kind of Republican are you
telling us to go to Russian TV and alga
zero
Republican ever I was interviewed by
David Frost on alzer I'm a I'm a loyal
follower of that Network and there
they're much more impartial than than
our networks are here yeah now
interestingly you really suffered from
this this partisan and corporate
conglomerate news controlled everything
because you pulled at one point to get
into one of the Fox News debates and
everybody was saying the entire election
cycle oh we need a republican who's
socially moderate and more okay with
abortion or gay rights that kind of
stuff uh but who's you know fiscally
conservative and strong for defense
which was precisely what your platform
was and Fox News was still pushing you
on the outside so that just goes to show
how partisan the the news organization I
think my what I speculate is that Romney
had something to do with that I was very
much uh going after Romney which is why
I was on Rachel mattow a lot because I
pointed out a lot of his shortcomings
and a lot of contradictions and and fox
left me off and I think the Romney
campaign threatened that he would be not
participating ating if that debate if I
was there because I was in that position
to um point out some of his problems so
that's my suspicion I don't know if Fox
necessarily did it um of their own
accord but I think that the uh opponents
uh that I was running against might have
had something to do with it yeah and it
looks like romy's probably going to be a
Fox News contributor now so that sort of
brings this thing full circle okay let's
uh let's move on I think we have a bit
of a good political news because that
does happen every now and again uh it
looks like Doma the defensive Marriage
Act
could be on the way out obviously
President Obama has done a lot of good
stuff when it comes to uh gay marriage
and marriage equality that's what we're
told we should call it um but because of
the Fifth Amendment which is equal
protection under the law they're now
saying that Dom is really indefensible
and Obama is probably not going to
defend it all adds up I have a feeling
that this panel is pretty much okay with
that I'm super gay and I am very excited
uh I would to you know be a human and uh
have the right basic rights I loved to I
circled this one part for the for the
house brief it said gays and lesbians
are one of the most influential best
connected best funded and best organized
interest groups in modern politics and
have attain more legislative victories
political power and popular favor and
less time than virtually any other group
in American history the house brief says
and I'm like yes uh with still no
rights yeah so if we could just get that
moving uh that would be fantastic all of
this is like you know pump and
Circumstance I'm like how how also some
basic rights yeah wasn't it so someone
last uh election cycle said the gay the
gay money is the new Hollywood money
that's what they uh that's what they
were saying what do you think about this
we it's time right I mean is there
anything to even debate here it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous that we are
in the 21st century and we are
discussing this uh that uh that it's a
basic civil rights issue and yet we know
was it Alabama just passed the 13th
Amendment
so you know could be a while still this
won't come out till tomorrow so it could
be flipped again but uh yeah so it's it
it astounds me that you know what it is
there's a section of our society our
culture that this white male established
Elite that really really wants to keep
it in
1952 wants the country to be there and
stay there and and that's when they were
in charge and it things are moving on
and it makes them nervous and so they're
doing everything they can to to to slow
it down and to and to and to demonize
every bit of the population that doesn't
stand with them so it's um so true it is
about time and I just I just hope hope
it finally finally happens yeah now Fred
I know this is cause is obviously uh
dear and near to your heart and you've
been fighting this thing from the inside
so give us a little sort of The Insider
steps of how you think this is now going
to play out well you know this goes back
to the seven 7s when we were getting
beat up and they were trying to ban gate
teachers in California and other states
and we've progressed to to
this unbelievable position where we are
now at the United States Supreme Court
thanks to Chad Griffin and a few other
tremendous Leaders with a lawsuit on on
two fronts one to try and um overturn
Proposition 8 which banned gay marriage
in California and now Anda which is this
was put in and signed by a democratic
President Bill Clinton is is completely
you now come out and opposed it is going
to be definitely turned down as will the
Supreme Court I think I'm I'm positive
actually um overturn Prop 8 and go along
with that decision we just won four
states in November which is unbelievable
and now for the first time the argument
they used the opponents used against
same-sex marriage was that the public is
against it well they're not now in four
states last November they passed it so I
think that Proposition 8 will rule um
the overturning of Proposition 8 and we
will just continue forward and and
there's cases moving forward which will
make marriage equality the law of the
land and what a message that sends to
younger people who struggled I had a
terrible time growing up gay it was just
I I had no self-esteem I was embarrassed
I was I mean it it was a very difficult
Road for me and I had it a lot better
than most and and kids are suffering
today and we see the suicides teenage
suicide so we need to make everyone in
this country equal yeah I mean you hit
on a lot of points there but I think one
of the the main things is that what I
think what's happened in the last year
or two is that we've learned that the
arguments against gay marriage are
completely insane you know what I mean
they always say well you're going to
destroy traditional marriage I don't
think that there is one study that has
proven where you've brought in gay
people to be allowed to be as regular
and boring as straight people that
suddenly straight marriages are
crumbling or that they said if you get
rid of don't ask don't tell the military
is going to suffer it's been over a year
now I don't think there's been one
instance and I'm if I'm wrong please
correct me that don't ask don't tell
being flipped has done anything you know
my favorite critic of this was the pope
yeah who was not there for long but he
said on the eve of the Spanish vote when
they voted to uh allow same sex marriage
he said that that gay marriage was
Insidious and dangerous and this was
three years ago in the height of the
priest abuse Scandal I'm thinking what
about that why doesn't he take on that
issue instead of attacking poor people
who are innocent and just want to be
happy and and marry the person that they
love and divorce rate is what like 56%
like they're doing it so well so I can't
what doing well it's it's completely
it's completely insane I have to say
though on a positive note I do so much
traveling for standup I mean to like
parts of the country where you're like
good how's this going to go no one
blinks no one has a problem with it when
I start talking about politics there's a
problem but when I literally talk about
like gay marriage and I start my like
gay marriage joke it's like people are
clapping like rural counties like across
the country so it's been super positive
and I think and Supreme Court
historically has never really taken on
such big social issues unless until like
the tide is turned they did that with uh
you know interracial marriage and so I
don't know it seems really positive
which is that's funny because we think
that you know Supreme Court justices are
there for life so that they can make
brave choices but as you said they
always wait until it's past the Tipping
Point and then they're like oh we did
this yeah yeah yeah all right but that
is all good news so uh we're happy about
that all right we got one more story for
you this week uh and I think it's a
fitting way to end all this we are
getting Dumber uh as a nation and a
world uh humans are getting dumber and
there is a plethora of reasons but of
course mostly it's because of the things
that we put in our bodies and I'm going
to read a couple of them to you uh
floride in the water supply is uh
hampering children's neurodevelopment
that's one of them uh pesticides are now
linked to lower intelligence levels and
decreased cognitive function which could
explain uh most of my friends and
and processed fruit processed fruits
which I'm sure are coming uh processed
foods specifically high fructose corn is
it fructose or fructose I had a debate
it's fructose I I've been having a lot
of that so not quite sure yeah uh high
fructose corn syrup or fructose has been
reduced uh linked to a reduced IQ I just
had a coke before we started and I think
that was complete evidence need coke
that has the real
Mama Mia okay so I proved it right there
but are we getting Dumber Fred are we
getting Dumber what was the question I
no I I think that's BS um one of my
favorite quotes is I think Mark Twain
really made it up but he said the the
three biggest lies are lies big lies and
statistics and as soon as the Almond
Board Association all the Almond Growers
came out and said that almonds have been
proven to decrease cancer risk and going
out and buying almonds I'm always
suspect as a political consultant we did
a lot of polling a lot of studies and
the ones that didn't quite turn out the
way we wanted we wouldn't necessarily
release and I think that's what we're
seeing here I think this is I don't know
who if the national resources defense
fund I don't know who are behind these
things but a lot of people there's if
you really dig deep you will see that
there is a selfish interest in these
studies a republican who doesn't believe
in scientific fact I'm shocked Kelly
what do you think I I'm I don't I'm kind
of torn on this one because you know I
look out I look out at I look out at the
world and I think yes we're definitely
getting Dumber yes uh it's it's getting
crazy out there uh but then again I
think about all of the ways in which we
are overwhelmed these days I mean I feel
overwhelmed by everything and I feel
Dumber but then I think it's also
middle-aged in hormones but I don't
know um that in there but that's not in
my notes here but I'll but you know what
here the general curve of civilization
if you think like from the you know the
pyramids to now you know generally I I
think we're on the uptick a little bit
maybe not a lot but I think it's a
general uptick I think humans are you
know we have a lot of challenges but you
know hey we went to the moon and someone
invented Twitter I don't know yeah these
feel like smart things to me Aaron
Dumber smarter what's up well I think
part of it is that that page where the
article was on also there was 79 things
on the page and it's like did you like
the article tweet about it Facebook
about it did you agree with that Google+
add your friends and I was like uh uh so
I think that is in fact part of it it
there's just so much going on that
you're just like you know I I I also
sort of agree that if you're uh you know
a pounding Fritos and Coke and you're
you know 900 lb and you're 10 U you're
not going to pick up a book you'd be
less likely maybe to take a nap than to
read so I think that is in fact a factor
but I also in all fairness I think I
don't see us really like in such a
horrible decline the article said that
he would bet like a average citizen from
Athens would be more you know you know
smarter and well I'm like all right well
come on you know if we were running
around and like sheets and sandals had
nothing else to do you know we'd be
reading more but there's we got a lot
going on it was just origies and reading
for those people wasn't it and weren't
there like gods in a sky on a Mountain
somewhere there was a lot of was there
like an oracle they like go to people
who were psychic and like read like I
mean Hello that hasn't changed yes I
mean wait a minute a Carlin giving a
shot to religion I don't believe it come
on now well you guys have given me a
little hope here I think with this story
I thought all three of you were going to
say yes we're getting Dumber I've been
dealing with dumb people every day and
uh you guys that is true uh that is true
there's a there's a there's a little bit
of truth that we isn't it always like
you know well those people are the D we
are the smart people we're on the panel
yeah and you just moved from New York so
does this La thing is I got to tell you
my vitamin D levels are peaking right
now and I do feel despite the intro to
this segment
uh just a little smarter than uh than I
used to and on that note RB I want to
thank you guys for watching rort oh by
the way our official Outfitter my
clothes my shirt oh my pants my shoes
brought to you by bonobos.com and you
can enter code Ruben report for 20% off
your first order I want to thank Aaron
Foley Fred carer Kelly Carlin and now
I'm going to let you guys pimp
yourselves out you Geniuses tell me
about yourselves go uh well I enjoy a
good flannel now and then so I'm going
to log on and give myself a discount
excellent really G it up uh I well my
website's Aaron kol.com
you can log on tour dates uh doing a lot
of stuff in LA and then
Austin Columbus Ohio Boston all kinds of
fun stuff on the road so lots of standup
excellent come to a show Fred Fred
car.com of course and um I'm uh trying
to get a job actually as a TV pundit so
uh if you're watching out there for any
of the networks this is H him what I
want to do but um I'm going to continue
my activism boycotting Amway which is
very homop iic and I'm going to be a
thorn in their side I think that was the
first time ever in the history of
internet or television that anyone was
asked to pimp themselves out and
actually asked for a
job that was really quite amazing Spain
tell us about yourselves I need
help I have no money Kelly Carlin and
gee strangely enough I have a website
kellyc car.com and uh but I'm going to
do my show a Carlin Home Companion March
23rd at the Acme theater here in
Hollywood and you can find me weekly on
smodcast at waking from the American
dream my podcast where I talk to all
sorts of people about all sorts of
things all right and I'm Dave Rubin and
if you're watching this then you found
me already so we're good to go I thank
you for watching and we'll see you next
[Music]
week